no heads up we're live nah we're live
hello world we're live we cancelled all
of Marvel is anyone here hello knock
three times if you can hear us hello
blink if you're in distress hello hello
gene
hello hello somebody anybody John
where's the chat says there are 89
pieces or a Thai people here about see
anyone gamma st. chats
oh oh oh wow chat just appeared for us
out of nowhere
I'm scared chat please don't hate hey
guys how you doing so John and I we got
a we got a whole like to podcast to film
right after this
whenever you see a man named PJ Campbell
buzz in and walk through the door that
means it's time and now there's already
157 people here let's talk about this
[ __ ] all right guys I got two main
things I want to talk about one Marvel
Netflix it's all done boom that's
happened
second thing how the Oscars are still
going to be boring as [ __ ] despite all
the controversy the past year nothing to
get excited about okay alright so
hopping right into this you know John
sure you've heard the news we've done
zero preparation on this we haven't
chatted a 1-bit about this well the only
thing I rather than going over every
single quote we could ever find about it
the only thing that gives some
resemblance of hope here is that Jeff
Lowe who is the TV show runner for all
the Marvel Netflix shows and he actually
responded to the cancellations and he
says something about towards the end of
his little thingy our network partner
may have decided they no longer want to
continue telling the tales of these
great characters but you know Marvel
better than that as Matt Murdock's dad
once said the measure of a man is not
how he gets not to the mat that's how he
gets back up gets back
up on the disney streaming service in
two years
hey and they've already shown that
they're not averse to r-rated material
that's true that's true
Deadpool the way is I feel I guess some
but you know what's weird okay iron fist
and and Luke Cage getting canceled
really bummed me out because I thought
iron fist was a major improvement and
what's up guys and I also really like
Luke a season two and then daredevil
getting canned that was a bummer for me
even though people saw my review and for
some reason thought I didn't like it I
did really liked his season a lot and so
I was very bummed about that cuz
Daredevils my fate now I am five
episodes into the Punisher season two
and I really have close to zero
motivation to continue this show because
I find it incredibly dull there you go
there's my review I'm trying to finish
it I probably will eventually weirdly I
think what has a good chance of going
out on the highest of high notes will be
Jessica Jones season 3 yeah because even
the showrunner herself she put out a
tweet and pretty much saying that will
be going out with a bang for our last 13
episodes when they air I think they were
aware they're gonna get cancelled so
there might as well give it their all
they probably got that notice like early
into their production yes cuz their
devil your because something got
canceled when they were like into
production so they probably had an
opportunity exactly so I feel like
Jessica John hey thanks you too bird oh
we need more youtubers out there and III
want to start making an effort to say
more positive things at the beginning of
the stuff and so I just wanted to say
that if there's a YouTube channel that
you guys know it has a patreon page you
want to go support them go ahead I'm not
saying go to our patreon page I've been
saying like you whoever your favorite
channels go out there or show them some
support their patreon if they have one
just like how you tubers showing us one
right now on this live stream thank you
guys so any hope yeah I want to clarify
something too I think Jon Bernthal him
The Punisher is a
amazing and every time he's on screen in
season 2 I love it and I thought the
first episode was great but as it kept
going is so less and less interested and
like the last Bernthal there is the more
bored I am so I'm hoping that when they
bring the Punisher back maybe in two
years from now because it's apparently
the contract goes that we can at least
get Jon Bernthal to return here I'll be
Jessica Jones I feel like this one I'd
say I'm the least bummed about this one
it's like we all a we all saw it coming
and B I'm not a big fan of The Punisher
season to him I have to finish it and
Jessica Jones I thought ceases who was
the first half of it was so boring and I
hated what they did with Trish Walker in
that episode man man I just want to put
this out there too not the actress she's
great she's fine but [ __ ] Trish water
hate her character I'm sure the actress
is a great human being I'm attacking the
problem not the person Trish Walker is
terrible character writing and the
conception yes for the TV yes so yeah I
would say I would say I'm not seems to
be like big news but oh my god whatever
I was waiting for this news to be honest
I mean I'm bummed to hear but I'm not at
all surprised especially when like
daredevil got canceled the second they
released that season like that seemed to
be the the true nail in the coffin I was
like oh yeah these are all going away
well what I find interesting about it
Jon see is from reading Jeph Loeb
statement it sounds like he's putting
the blame on Netflix
everybody has put the blame on things
across all these cancellations they said
it like multiple times actors have come
out into mind no it wasn't Disney was
Netflix this decision and they made it
which is pretty interesting because I
thought it was a joint thing I thought
it might have been like oh we want them
for our I thought it might have been
something behind the scenes that we're
just not aware about with the Disney
streaming service or whatever that they
just haven't put out there but it seems
like the creators and everyone involved
themselves is going hey it's actually
Netflix we wanted to keep it go yeah
maybe this was all part of the plan like
maybe Disney really does want to
continue these shows and their streaming
service there
look if you don't make us look like the
bad guy for canceling these for a couple
years we will give you so much money
that you can just make a million
original series and that so who knows
maybe there's a conspiracy afoot I don't
know but I don't know I'm hoping I am
surprised because it seemed like those
were some of their most lucrative and at
least discussed online shows and of
course Netflix is famous for not ever
releasing their stats but with this many
original series in as much kind of
expensive-looking content as they have
out there I am surprised that these
aren't their flagship so I guess I mean
at one point they were though yeah the
the show's used to be like an event you
know that this daredevil came out it was
an event with Jessica Jones like they
were all an event Iron Fist was like
yeah and then the defenders came out and
everyone was like once they open once
everything started to get okay I do
think like the the luster started to die
out yeah people but I still think it was
great Andrew Hayes I'm right there with
you buddy
hi Greg for iron fist and I wouldn't do
my own interpretation I would just try
to bring the Finn Jones for sure it is
definitive he was he's like Wolverine
and Hugh Jackman man yeah you owe it to
I would not try to I wouldn't do any
comic book research I would just go how
can I bring the Finn Jones back yeah
just dye your curl you know on any rate
that that Finn Jones was he's forever
that's why how how he was never as
strong as the supporting characters
around watching yeah you know okay
whatever you just keep saying how Oh
bummer and yeah honestly we all saw it
coming yeah and it's whatever I want to
move on really quick and then we'll read
a little bit more your guys comments I
want to talk about the Oscars really
quick oh yeah I just want to remind
everyone it's gonna be as boring as ever
okay this because if you noticed the
Oscars has I just I cannot recall in my
entire life when the Oscars had this
much controversy yeah I know they look
like idiots like the pauper
or Film category of heard yeah they do
the popular film category thing was just
the whole bust this the whole Kevin Hart
thing is a bust and then you got the
editing and cinematographer and then
everyone petition now they have it back
in there
so the it's had all this controversy
which is weirdly probably gonna make
more people tune in to go what are they
gonna [ __ ] do this Sunday you know the
the right laborat scheme but I'm telling
you guys it's gonna be just as boring as
ever like I I part of me is on that
mindset of going oh I want to see what
they do now wanna see what all the
craziness going on and no Oates but I'm
like it's gonna probably be just as dull
as every year fascinating show cuz I
truly don't know what anybody actually
just wants from it I just know what
everybody doesn't like about it and
doesn't need and the funny thing to me
is somebody pointed out is that they
made this big deal about like oh we want
to cut the show down for time so we're
gonna take out these awards but yeah
their original idea was do this popular
awards category which would add more
time so I don't think they've ever
really had a solid concept of what they
want to do to this year's show they just
need it to have ratings well I was
hearing that they they were really gonna
have two of the songs be and I heard
this one scream druggies News I'm
totally stealing from them they they say
they're gonna have to of this over the
denominator songs are yeah I was like
that was something else
Lady Gaga's said she wouldn't perform
unless all of them were there so they
all you know that's not gonna cooperate
and said alright yeah we'll get everyone
I mean good to perform good for if one
group is gonna perform everybody has to
yeah like especially if that they like
immediately conceded to but this other
[ __ ] we need to like petitions and an
out for so yeah guys I would just say
the this weird Oscars is already kind of
strange
it's like judging art is looking strange
but and he's gonna be just as dull as
every year all right it's gonna be the
Superbowl especially because like more
so than even in Reese
just seemed like nobody agrees on who
and what got nominated and how any of
this is working yeah I don't know who
this year's show is for all right well
those are my thoughts yeah it is like
this would be a lot easier to get those
quick opinions out there that people
have been tweeting me about wanting to
know about and I figured I just hop on
here really quick and just say it to you
guys but Wow looks like people are
talking about Donald shrunk in our live
stream you know I've been wanting to
make this channel more political mm-hmm
I've been wanting to cause the political
regions so I'm really hoping we can get
this Trump train rolling in here or if
there's any questions you guys have
now's your time to try to get our
attention
and like any YouTube or if it's a super
chat you definitely can I guess the way
we want to where we roll here front line
just like that everyone left this the
live stream because Gregg pointed out
the thing that youtubers don't point out
but are all thinking that's the way I'm
going to say it because I'm not supposed
to I'm gonna use reverse psychology
don't send us any super valuable
we don't need super Jasper here for like
we do like cheese Callum Jackson who do
you think should play the next Batman we
ever did a whole livestream about this
we're not gonna do this yeah Trump all
the way 2020 he doesn't have my vote
telling you guys that much look at that
eight people a lot let's see how many if
we can physically get everyone a log off
that would be amazing
all right we just have to start really
awful things let's just start spouting
off racist epithets remember I remember
last year oh no guys we're gonna be in
the free-for-all for the Schmo down in
case you guys don't know that yeah so
John you better do a great job pressures
on man you did a great job the first
time the second time John you let
everyone down I know I blew ting myself
to the complete 180
whoa zeroing out ten dollar super chat
hey you're my new best friend on this
livestream
again where did I get this defender
shirt my girlfriend got it for me Olivia
from Comic Con right there and this was
actually the outfit that Finn Jones was
going to wear in season two before they
pull up as being about that but I got it
from Comic Con and you should DM my girl
with a dick pic I'm telling you she will
probably send you one as well that's how
easy it is to snag her she is very
unfaithful - yeah very fickle yeah very
the way it goes
fickle for the dude okay John point out
something point out something here ooh
if someone wants us to make those racist
comments we promised no sir somebody had
a question though that I thought was
neat Oh somebody said what do you think
of Captain Marvel will it suck and I
feel like it's fascinating that that's
the only thing I hear is that just
everyone's convinced this movie is gonna
suck what
oh dude YouTube birthing Keys everyone
go subscribe to youtubers page right now
subscribe to the uber the original
original youtuber the first one there we
go we've made our money's worth we're
ready to get out of here now because
YouTube it's all about money and making
money off of your subscribers yes like
everyone go to our patreon and put out
your hard-earned cash during jury
Clinton Sandin ooh your foreskin is not
my other youtubers are not trying to uh
you know just collab with us as much
anymore specifically me youtuber wanted
to okay well I think Captain Marvel is
gonna be great I think they just
confirmed who Jude Law's character is I
actually bought the tie-in comic just
last night okay
his Jude Law's character I think is
gonna be called yeah I'm sure after
someone in the chat is putting it out
there but it was confirmed young Rob who
is a famous Captain Marvel villain and
it was interesting that I was reading in
this article they were pointing out is
that a lot of people on the Kree team
which is what they call themselves
creatine creatine is that a lot of them
are bad guys yeah
so it's probably that's probably why she
gets stranded here back on earth craters
hey you know what I noticed it's only
the men who are talking [ __ ] on Captain
Marvel and you guys need to get your
dick out of your own asses Tyler hey
thanks so much buddy
the man who's the reason I could play a
Red Dead r2c dude if you're pregnant and
use a vibrator will you have a baby that
stutters scientifically proven yeah man
yeah definitely absolutely yeah that's a
fact I've tested it out my girl oh I'm
having a baby I forgot to tell you guys
my girlfriend's pregnant we're having a
baby
Olivia I forgot to tell you you're
pregnant and you're having a kid so good
luck there man I won't be around I'm
abandoning you because I use the
vibrator on her and now the baby's gonna
have a stutter
oh you can't raise a stuttering child
how could you we should host the office
we should host the Oscars that would be
funny we can revise like it's good wins
does feel like it should have a star is
born
yes I just want to be the first ask ur
host oh you guys are gonna love this one
yeah they gave its aroma everyone's
favorite movie dear look we got Best
Makeup going let's get them 10 extra
minutes on the clock
everyone once they hear my favorite
Maury Povich moment I'll tell you my
favorite experience for watching Maury
Povich all right because I used to watch
it religiously during the summer time
you ever much more I found out who my
dad was on this show oh did you huh huh
poor black man so okay well I used to go
to a barber someone brought in my head -
being shaved was a cat doing in the
background doing cat things I had you a
one time I got my head shaved like just
pure shave and I was at a barber and
then looking in the mirror as they were
doing it and the reflection of that was
the Maury Povich Show so I was watching
it at a reverse
and then I was watching some episode I
cannot remember what but I'm at a
barbershop with a bunch of like tough
ass Latino dudes and I started I just
start crying a reflection in the mirror
that is going on in the March I remember
what it was but man you to make me cry
so yeah hey where's that uh oh oh we got
it we got a new Mouse so we could scroll
yeah we answer that if you're pregnant
with the vibra I thought I was a file
you want the punishment back here's five
dollars to bring it to start a petition
and bring it back
but dude the Punisher okay honestly I'm
gonna start looking at the common sir so
the guys who have watched Punisher
season - do you get do you guys uh do
you do you guys like that season
honestly because I can't I can't finish
it I just I can't I've started episode
five so many times I just can't get
through it but I love Jon Bernthal my
favorite actors yeah he's terrific like
he's always great wherever he goes and
he who also loves jumper though John
come on free for all time who's the guy
who directed a hell or high water Tyler
Durden Oh Taylor Taylor kids Taylor
Hackford Taylor Taylor Taylor Taylor
gergan Taylor he did know he's a writer
yeah there's a writer of hell or high
water
he did his Sheridan there we go
I noticed Taylor Sheridan loves making
Jon Bernthal a [ __ ] hell or high water
I know it is a kid not know asakari
yeah yeah yeah it's Sicario he shows up
gets his ass right yeah and then he
makes it cameo in hell or high water is
it not hell Water Bridge on the River
Kwai
I prayed in the pre-emptive city is
nasty part of the yeah but at least he's
a more stand-up guy that's true he tries
valiantly and does not succeed thoughts
on Jeff Nichols he is remaking a movie
here called alien nation my thoughts on
it Rick since we have done funk $2 for
us for the super chat our I I don't
think they should do it right is that
the feeling I'm supposed to have that's
how remakes work is no no don't do it
don't do it
alien nation is a bona fide classic and
no development could ever be better
don't do it oh hey okay look this guy's
saying stop wasting your time with a
personal hatred towards Marvel I don't
know if he's talking directly to us but
if he is I hate Marvel and I lie during
every reaction just to get views I
dedicate three hours a day to just going
online finding Marvel things and
[ __ ] on them because it's my duty
half of the hate comments are me yeah
you know I don't even watch the Marvel
movies I just read the negative reviews
and then I quote them in my reviews yeah
we'll all your Game of Thrones Season
eight reactions be on YouTube - we're
gonna try we're gonna try I know a
couple of them got blocked of for season
seven we're trying to avoid some
copyright strike stuff yeah but we we
are actively are the goal is to do it
I'm letting you guys know that the goal
is to do that because Game of Thrones
Season eight is easily gonna be the
second biggest show this year next to
Jessica Jones yeah definitely be numb
that's gonna enclose the whole thing
yeah easily the end of Marvel Netflix as
we know it
Carter Lovejoy has a fun question here
Game of Thrones or Lord of the Rings you
see buddy
I would say if The Hobbit films were
awesome I would say Lord of the Rings
but now I'm gonna say I'm gonna say Game
of Thrones ask me again when Game of
Thrones wraps up but as a completed
story I think Laura the Rings is more so
yes as just yeah I mean you're
outnumbered by seasons to move
but I would go where the rings personal
Hey Lynnae Jones I'm letting you know
LeMay I have just made it to season five
of that 70s show Hey
yeah I'm loving it man and I just
watched Topher Grace and black clans
just weird one very similar the last
thing I know I watched an episode of
That 70's Show over your shoulder and
then the very next time I saw him he was
David dear gene your video will be up
this week everyone go to gene Jeter's
channel he is a white guy who made a
poem called white privilege and he is
just gloating so much she's being white
about how much he loves being white and
he's also a photographer on his page of
his Instagram where it's a bunch of very
obese male models so you guys should
just go there go check it out these are
our top zeroing out your sarcasm is epic
Wow that's our cast $20 the super chat
for being sarcastic now is that's not
always the money at all but now let me
let riddle me this zeroing out is this a
sarcastic super chat like you're going
your sarcasms epic here's 20 bucks
I'm just curious are going to get better
microphones for our podcast so yeah this
is investment so thank you guys
worst peanuts Charlie Brown specials uh
I don't know I mean my dad really
hitting the Thanksgiving I was good
Thanksgiving yeah my dad hates that one
I don't dislike it I think it's the
weakest of all the ones I've seen cuz
you know they just come over to his
house and they're dicks and then he
makes them dinner yeah see I don't like
I don't dislike that one I don't it wait
a minute I never saw it oh well that's
what it was
there you go I saw the Christmas one and
I really liked that Christmas ones it is
gorgeous
it's it's not assessable you know that's
what we call the Mandela effect you
should just live the rest of your life
as though you had seen it
yaws earring out what's your real name
so it's hard to keep up with all these
comments guys chats will be very
different place if you can reflect
sarcasm and other expressions in chat
will save a lot of miscommunication too
you see I don't believe in clarifying my
statements as often as people would like
to you know I think it's time to bring
back a lot of sexist jokes and racist
jokes I'm gonna start the wave of
comedians going on social media wanting
to joke about whatever they want so just
letting you know I'm bringing back that
humor starting tomorrow night yeah man
things aren't aren't raunchy and
irreverent enough I think we could get
edgier I think Ryan Ryan needs to come
back he's saying fire always confuse
fire saying always confuse you with
Jabby yes that does this confuse you
with javi okay all right guys we're
gonna log off in just a minute because
we need to set up to do this a couple of
podcast requests here for some patrons
gene don't worry man I'm sending people
to go to your video don't you fret don't
you Frank
okay I'm gonna scroll way to the top
here I'm gonna just see what comment
that since we missed so many comments oh
it says I thought Mike Kalinowski wanted
you to shave your head I was like what
is he doing
favorite movie out of the Cornetto
trilogy and why he's Shaun of the Dead
probably Shaun definitely Shaun of the
Dead after that oh definitely yeah they
just got worse worse much worse dude
damn right my brother's muscles were a
bigger one he's like got that I don't
know his muscles look really dense
I hate bumping into him at the gym he
just goes shows up it just tells me what
I'm doing wrong
yeah just comes over he's like hey Titan
is oh no matter how much weight and
muscles I've gained like just like now
you're doing this wrong I wish I had do
better yeah whoo there's a question
Gotham ER daredevil ooh I'm only two
seasons in the daredevil before I can
make that conclusion so who else is
gonna be the next one to get a tattoo
guys who's the next one to get a real
Rejects tattoo clothes [ __ ] early with
our hard-working live streams like this
yeah more people should be getting and
our our tattoo you should be doing that
right away gene I cannot wait to see
your tattoos hang it on my ass it's
being hidden on this chat I'm making it
public oh I cannot yeah please make it
film I want to see your ass pass
yeah real regrets tattoo oh that's for
that's for that real regret rejects that
to you that's yeah
get that ass sad bad okay
any word on Rick and Morty season four
yes they tell me specifically and it's
coming out next year guys a youtuber
thanks for being here buddy okay so yeah
we got a few podcast ones were filming
this week I'll tell you guys what the
topics are have them all written down
and organized podcast stream a branch
and ler tomorrow we are one is about
separating art from the artist and the
other one is straight actors playing gay
people or like transgenders you know
stuff like that the homosexuals being
played by the heteros people of
different orientations playing each
other but today we're gonna put we're
gonna talk about heavier topics like
franchises continuing after a certain
amount of time whether they should be
sequels or reboots that's gonna be the
whole title and the other one is like
talking about bond versing Ethan Hunt
not like who would win in a fight just
you know which franchise we prefer and
why which stack of DVDs would win in a
fight between two stacks of DVDs well
easily the Mission Possible because
people forget there's a show so just all
DVDs and those were over a pile
yeah they don't even have blu-ray to so
you get so many discs or so wait for
that trailer reaction for Citizen Kane
the whole strength along come
you're laymen we cut down into reaction
highlights only 10 minutes took about a
half hour to edit yeah Orson Welles
keeps claiming it from beyond the grave
all right guys this is gonna be the last
question we answer what do you think
about the new choke yeah obviously we're
excited Jesus we've been on the record
as excited but especially sad that Jared
Leto's Joker movie got cancelled finally
no man now we got to watch and play a
vampire oh that's actually a little
better yeah I guess so I'm more okay
with that okay guys come on give us one
good question to go out on a high note
on one good question I did know there's
a doctor I don't know why John hasn't
been on movie fights yet you should ask
them eyes are afraid I'm gonna destroy
the whole show by winning too hard and
getting a championship in my first try
yeah they're gonna be like wow we didn't
even know this is possible but the belts
here how'd you do that John I feel like
shouldn't let me on your show let's see
what is love just be quiet
what's going on all right screw it we
could do these is ASM screwy I'm just
gonna get okay what's going on with New
Mutants all right let's talk about this
New Mutants I think it's gonna be an
okay movie I think it's gonna have the
worst expectations and ultimately we're
all gonna go who's fine yeah Mike he's
fine weirdly I feel like it's gonna be
one of those movies that comes out where
you're like I can tell that this was
like Frankenstein together so it
probably doesn't have an actual tone or
pace but yeah it's like and next one no
Trump will be president for eight more
years definitely guys I want to thank
you all for being here in this live
stream thank you all who have
contributed to the super chat you're the
reason why this country keeps on moving
in this direction it is and it's because
of you guys why I occasionally do these
and also yeah and then whatever other
youtubers say I love all of you because
I know all of you personally you're all
my close friends love you so I'm here
for you if you ever need help
yeah talk to me you guys are just all
thousands of you talk to me you guys all
of you have been watching since the
beginning and whoever starts watching
always continues watching there's never
a new people and there's never like oh
this person left and all of these people
why that's not how it goes
I love you personally yeah we're gonna
come to your house and cuddle with you
like this